let's do this we got a bunch of stories
but let's start with yours because um
it's i mean you've done a local
interview but is this like the first big
discussion you've had about what
happened on january 6th i did a local
interview with uh with mike calta super
nice guy he's he's been to radio for a
long time he's really nice to me and
he's like you know i'd love to have a
chat with you wasn't speaking negative
or anything so i was like yo i'll come
talk with you and i did another one with
um with a guy who just reviews guns i'm
not going to give a shout out because i
don't know he's he's still building you
know but um super nice guy we just kind
of chatted about what happened so uh
you're the podium guy and this is uh an
egregious incorrect statement because it
was a lectern and uh everybody is
telling us that in the chat but uh so
you know for those aren't familiar
there's this famous photo that comes out
of the january 6 riots or whatever it's
you and you're carrying the lectern
while smiling and waving to the camera
and uh
how did it all happen what's the story
behind it
i mean how far do you want to go back
like why did i go i mean let's just
start with like yeah yeah sure tell us
your story man so um i wasn't really
into politics a few years ago i'm busy
raising kids changing diapers and doing
common core math you know and um kovic
struck and i started listing as i had
more free time just trying to find a
hobby and uh
you know followed the elections and
everything you know listened to a bunch
of stuff and uh i had never voted before
i voted and i voted in 2019
for the first time i've registered
independent forever just didn't really
have much stake in getting out there and
doing something because my life was
pretty good you know
and uh listen to what was going on
started getting some opinions some ideas
and i decided i'm gonna go to a trump
rally it's gonna be the last one you
know i'd never been to one before you
know i always listen to the guys twitter
was hilarious you know so um i bought
some tickets with a friend of mine and
we just headed up there
and uh it was the first rally i've been
to never been to a protest before it's
kind of a new experience for me so i
didn't really know the etiquettes of
what a protest is did you go to he was
trump was speaking at the ellipse yes
did you go there yes that's where he was
by the monuments and the world war the
world war ii memorial how did you go
from there to the capitol building over
there for um
i think about a couple hours and uh at
the very end of his speech he's like
we're gonna march down to the capitol or
the march peacefully let our voices be
heard you know and uh we didn't really
have any plans that day you know after
the fact so i was like well i guess
it's going there so i guess we'll follow
so you know just following cattle
so you follow people you make it to the
capitol building
what happens next
so when we um on the walk there we
actually there's a lot of people there
i've never seen so many people
we heard from the crowd
pence didn't do it pence didn't do it
it's over you know and at that point
people are just there the pace picks up
some people start running you know
they're funneling through the crowd and
i'm like what's going to happen you know
so i follow because i'm curious i'm
there to see what happens i'm there to
witness a little bit of history and i
follow the crowd when we get to the
capitol it's already under siege you
know i compare it to like watching um
uh like an ant hill being kicked you
know just just people everywhere
but so but elaborate on that did you see
violence did you see people tearing
things down oh yeah there was definitely
violence there that day and you know i
try to be as honest as possible like
people were hitting cops
as you're walking up you're seeing all
that happen yes yep i'm filming it i'm
watching it go down i mean when i first
got there they were kind of just arguing
back and forth you know you protest
rhetoric you know you've betrayed us you
know defend our country this and that
and at some point just
things popped off you know one side
started pushing their side pushed back
there was tear gas mace there was a
flash bang at a point you know but
people were hitting cops
so
well so so next what's next so i don't
want to stick around that because i
don't want to be a part of that you know
i'm just kind of tacitly sitting back
there videotaping it because
holy cow what's happening in front of me
you know so the next thing uh i climb up
some scaffolding to kind of get a bird's
eye view to see what's happening
and um you can't tell where the things
start and stopped i mean it was just
funneling in for almost every street you
know i was kind of beholding the whole
thing and you know it's kind of like
well i'm not sure what to do next you
know as i come down the stairs from the
scaffolding i notice people are going
inside the building and i'm like well i
guess that's where the protest is going
i guess i'll go inside you know so i
walk through open doors with a group of
people
um i get to uh the rotunda and when we
get there people kind of disperse
because it's such a large room you know
it's a beautiful room too so you know
whatever people were walking in with a
chance it got real quiet real quick
people are looking around at the
paintings the statues the oculus i mean
it's it's it's a beautiful room
and then um i kind of wander around a
little bit take some pictures and i
notice there's uh there's this lectern
sitting kind of like underneath some
stairs it's kind of out in the open i'm
like man that would make a great photo
you know kind of in the middle of the
rotunda i called it you know i nailed it
and um so i take the lectern out i set
it down i give a short speech and then i
go wander around a little bit more
so that was that photo of you carrying
the lectern was you you took it from
under some stairs and then and then what
you put it down somewhere i put it down
in the middle of the rotunda and then
you started talking to people yeah i
just i gave a short speech it was like
three lines
you know kind of a kind of larping
politics you know
and um i left it there i didn't put it
back where i find it you know so shame
on me
but um after that i walked away um i
went down um i saw where the speaker the
house is kind of hallway is so i kind of
walked down there i saw a nancy pelosi
store i'm like holy cow
that's where she does her stuff
you know
and so um you know i i touched the
doorknob i got it i did touch the
doorknob i didn't try to open the door
it's like a boop you know and uh but the
door was lost like all right well walk
away from that so i come back down the
hallway kind of getting bored kind of
getting lost never been to the capitol
before and i see another group of people
that are coming in that's a whole other
wave and they kind of seem like they
know where they're going that they they
know they have a plan or whatever you
know so i follow that group
and uh this group heads down towards i
think it's the senate chamber where they
were and so i kind of tag along with the
group you know i'm texting my wife
texting my friends and you're like oh
i'm inside you know like you should
leave i'm like i'll leave in a minute
i'll leave him i guess more pictures so
um we get down to the doors and uh you
know they're banging on the doors and
stuff and kind of just you know looking
around taking pictures i talked to a guy
next to me and i'm like what are they
doing like oh that's where they are and
i was like what do you mean that's where
they are it's like that's that's where
they're meeting to count the votes like
they're still here what are they doing
here you know said that but i'm like i
probably shouldn't be here you know so
um i do one around for fewer minutes uh
someone releases either tear gas or some
type of fire extinguisher
and uh you know hurts my eyes it burns
and
yeah yeah it's not comfortable you know
so um i went around a little bit more i
found a cop and asked cop hey man how do
i get out of here i'd like to leave now
and uh the cop tells me well you know go
down the hallway take a right there's an
officer out there he's
uh taking people accident outside so
just go over there you'll be done
and that was my experience inside the
capitol and so then you leave you leave
the capitol
and then uh you had no i did you have
any idea what was about to come in terms
of the national attention the photo no
no i knew a photographer had taken my
picture because you know professional
photographers pretty easy to spot you
know but i didn't think anything would
come of it i thought well like trespass
you know worst case scenario tell me i
can't come back again but i got my
photos i saw the building i'm good you
know you thought you were trespassing i
mean
yeah
yeah i mean i could admit that i mean i
did walk into a building i'm pretty sure
they didn't want me inside of so i can
say yes i did trespass so after you
leave
um
what like when did you when did you find
out that it was much more serious than
you had realized so my phone had died
inside i had a charging in my backpack
on a um on a battery pack and uh i made
it outside uh got a couple hot dogs was
walking back to the hotel and uh turned
the phone back on after hit like 10 15
percent and my phone just started
blowing up man couldn't even use it
because there were so many messages
coming in uh eventually i put on
airplane mode so i can kind of go
through see what was going on and uh it
struck me because there were so many
people like dude you're famous there are
memes of you i was like well that didn't
go as planned you know so um
before i even made it back to my hotel i
was getting recognized on the street
when did you uh find out that you are in
serious trouble
um so i made it back to the hotel room
and it was when i started watching cnn
and cnn had told uh the people that this
is an insurrection uh these people
should go to prison for 20 years
you know and then i found someone got
shot and i'm like oh my lord that's
that's really really bad and things
started evolving from there
when did like when did you first make
contact with law enforcement how did it
come to be that you end up you know
facing charges well i'm friends with
quite a few leos
um so like i called a couple i'm like
hey is this gonna be a big deal
and uh they did allude to they did say
like they're probably gonna want to have
a conversation with you at some point
you know because what you did is what
they're saying you did
and uh so i i called a couple of friends
of mine a good buddy of mine uh his name
is jennings i'm supposed to say jennings
good buddy of mine jennings uh he said
uh he said look i got a couple of
lawyers you should give them a call just
do it ahead of time get get some defense
set up because things are probably not
going to be great for you in the weeks
to come
so
go ahead so then what happens you get uh
you get you know you call some lawyers
do they eventually uh do they make
contact with the feds or the feds come
to you or what yeah so uh my attorneys
david bigni and dan eckhart fantastic
people i highly recommend them i'm also
shout them out um so uh i got a hold of
them and they're like listen this is
gonna be a case of a lifetime you don't
wanna wait you need to get us hired
because they're going to come after you
hard you don't get to get a photo like
that and become you know infamous
overnight and not see them come after
you
so um we got the prices from i was like
oh well
i'm not going to pay that that's absurd
you know but we did can you say what
those prices are um i was a hundred
thousand dollars wow yeah to hire him
yeah
it's a hundred thousand dollars and uh
we're paid off now so we're fine and god
is good but um
we did end up hiring them and i i had a
flight that was supposed to leave on
friday but i rented a car like that
night picked it up in the morning and
drove back because i knew like charges
are probably coming and i'd like to see
my family for a couple hours before they
pick me up
when did the charges come the charges
came on on a friday about how long after
i left uh thursday morning around 6 a.m
and the next week and no the next day oh
the next friday the next day yeah within
i think within 48 hours i was
the ausa which is the assistant united
states attorney's office was already in
contact with my attorneys and vice versa
and uh they were talking about these are
the charges we're bringing and uh he's
gonna have to go to jail until we'll
figure something out what were the what
were the initial charges they wanted to
get you on uh it was a violent entry
which is a misdemeanor it was um
entering and remaining uh restricted
building which is a misdemeanor and then
um it's glorified trespassing and then
uh felony theft for moving furniture 20
yards
you did not end up with the felony or
anything how so so so how does it how
does it end up you know with your your
criminal case where are you at now uh so
again my attorneys are awesome um i'm
not a felon which is fantastic i get my
voting rights back which are very
important to me and i also get my
firearms back which are equally
important to me which is good um i did
75 days in a uh in a federal prison camp
and then i did um five thousand dollar
fine and i got 200 hours of community
service but i'm enjoying my community
service what kind of stuff are you doing
is community service i am working uh for
an organization called um
adopt a cop which was uh
founded for um it was after uh george
floyd i believe it was after george
floyd i got to read the statement again
but uh basically training cops in jiu
jitsu to be able to
subdue suspects in a non-lethal manner
so i work with with law enforcement
officers doing training programs rolling
with them i've got a big function i'm
organizing a couple weeks i can't talk
about yet but it's it's i'm enjoying it
that's awesome yeah i'm enjoying it so
you end up uh
in a prison camp you said yes what what
is what what is that is that not a big
you know cell block with razor wire or
what does that mean so um i didn't know
anything about prison before this
started so my idea of prison is like
shawshank redemption
you know
and uh in green mile so i was not super
thrilled about it um they have i guess
four i think it's four different levels
of prison so there's like mac security
where like the motorists go there's a
medium which is you know not as bad as
scalable and then there's low and then
there's camp
and they place you based on your charge
and there's like five different levels
of things where it's like you know are
you have gang ties you know is your is
it a violent record how many times
you've been arrested uh recidivism and
uh
there was something else you can't
recall so it's a camp you're like are
you like outside with like a fire
roasted marshmallows or what it's not
it's not that nice um so it's not like
it's not stills not cages you know it's
like open dorms you've seen orange is
the new black no
open door so you can come and go as you
please or what uh
typically yeah like they're in and out
of your room obviously in any room yeah
there's yes i mean there's times you
have there's curfew you have to be in uh
there's also wake up time you have to be
up and they give you jobs to do uh in
the camp uh the prisoners do everything
they do the cooking they do the laundry
they do the lawn maintenance they do
everything they keep you busy oh so what
did you have to do i did nothing i told
them i'm not going to work oh really i
will not work for the government you
cannot make me
so they didn't make it no so let's let's
go back to this day on january 6th it
sounds like from the story you've told
us you had you had no real idea what was
going to happen no you had no plans nope
you had no real intentions nope i wanted
to see an end of an error it was gonna
be trump's last hurrah and i thought
that would be a great thing to witness a
little bit of history and uh you make
your way into the capital kind of just
bumbling and not really understanding
what was going on around you like a
little bit like you knew there was
fighting you knew there was trespassing
but you were just kind of like oh i left
the group of people who were fighting
because that's not what i am that's not
what i agree with so there were group
people are doing that and i said those
aren't my people so i went and i found
something else to do i think you know
the reason why i want to hit on that is
obviously the narrative is insurrection
and all that and while i certainly think
there are people who are rioting and you
know trying to do something the reason i
don't like the phrase insurrection is
that the idea that several hundred
people can stand in a building and
change a government is like absurd it's
not the 1600s anymore and even then it's
like that that it didn't even work for
hitler right the the the what is it the
the beer hall push he like fires a gun
in there and declares he's taking the
government over and just come and arrest
him like what do you what do you think
this is uh and then he had to hitler's
rise to power was actually through
politics because just trying to stand in
the building doesn't accomplish anything
i think that's an important distinction
with everything we're hearing um
especially with your story obviously
doesn't speak to the people who were
fighting and you know one guy was like
brutally hitting a cop he got serious
charges and he should be in prison for
that absolutely you you like you don't
go and beat people for any reason no you
know but but i think the important thing
is that a lot of the people who are
there uh
there's there's two things one in your
case you knew they were fighting you
knew you were trespassing you got
convicted you you you pleaded uh to a
misdemeanor charge then you went to
prison there are some people who watched
the police open the door and fan them in
yes this guy what was his name matthew
martin i think his name was that his
name
acquitted on all charges because the
judge said there's a video showing a cop
waving him in and then the cops are
saying i agree with it and then cops
taking selfies with people
getting getting to fully understand this
is extremely important if we're going to
you know actually move forward with this
kind of like in this country and try and
solve these problems well it's case by
case and i think the problem with
calling an insurrectionist they're
calling mean insurrection as the
evidence direction that says you
you're generalizing statements right it
is case by case some people did
something some people did other things
but it's a blanket statement everything
is i think horrible like i mean so i
tell people
i tell people it's kind of like looking
what happened with uh with the summer of
love right i'm sure there are a lot of
people that showed up to a protest that
turned into a riot you know and i can't
i support protests in all forms if
you're angry about something you don't
like how something's going go protest go
vote you're allowed to speak as i mean
currently you know but go do something
about it you know not violent don't
encourage that but i tell them you can't
just call all the black lives matter all
riders because there are a lot of people
there that were just protesting you know
and so i won't blanket statement that at
all i won't but i want the same courtesy
also given to some of us that were there
that were just protesting but there is
still
for
at these black lives matter protests and
on january 6 there are people who i
guess january 6 is a little bit
different but on for these for these
protests where black lives matter for
instance in portland were throwing fire
bombs there were people who were
providing cover whether intentionally or
not and a certain point it's kind of
like if you're standing there and you're
watching people throw fire bombs at a
building and you're like well i'm gonna
remain a part of whatever this is like
at a certain point you are playing a
role in that sure sure so i guess maybe
the same thing extends to us as well
like you know if we if we solve things
and didn't leave i mean maybe that
extends that as well by that logic
i think so um and i wanted i want to
draw the sting between the people
who were led in by cops and the people
who were there watching the fighting or
fighting themselves sure the issue with
that is i certainly don't think you you
should you deserve to be called an
insurrectionist or be charged with
felonies because other people were
fighting
but you were part of a riot the police
have to deal with you as much as they
have to deal with people who are
fighting but the people who are fighting
are the ones causing them a problem and
then you know be it black lives matter
at january 6 being part of this big
crowd and coming in and coming out is
straining the resources to try and stop
the violence absolutely and i think it's
a
i don't know why they're putting so many
reasons towards it i mean there's plenty
of other things that i think most people
would rather have solved than a couple
of people who are walking around taking
selfies well low hanging fruit
you you you know that that photo of you
is iconic
everybody's everybody's seen it and it's
you know the look on your face is
confidence
so for for the left they view you as
this arrogant guy who is
engaging in this behavior with no
remorse and on the right they view it as
defiance sure that's everybody but so
you know they have to strike at symbols
sure sure and i think so like it is by
phasing i mean you can feel multiple
emotions at the same time you know so
there's part of me where it's like holy
cow look where i am you know so a smile
will
definitely come from that where it's
you're witnessing history and things are
going crazy so maybe it's a nervous
smile you know maybe it's anxious but at
the same time i mean there's also fear
that i'm feeling at the same time
because where is our country going in
what the heck is happening here so uh
you somehow managed to uh you got
approval to come on the show is that
what happened i did yeah um initially it
was a no
um i requested my po office it's
probably gonna get me in trouble it's
fine i requested my uh my po office hey
i'd like to go uh travel to do this
podcast it's you know i watch you guys
all the time i thought that'd be a
really good experience
and he seemed pretty cool with it up
front and the reason i had to ask to
travel is because uh part of my
restrictions uh being on uh probation or
supervised release is i have to stay in
the middle district of florida i can't
leave that i've been there for the past
almost two years while i was under a
pre-trial
indictment so the opportunity to travel
is like i really want to be able to do
that again
so i contacted the po it's like it
shouldn't be a problem let me let me run
it up the ladder you know and we'll you
know we'll talk about it a couple of
days pass you know it's like why don't
you why don't you come in we'll have a
conversation in person
so i come in for the conversation in
person and um
it's it's implied and i don't want to
throw in the bus because these people
are doing their jobs and
we can debate that later but
he um he's like you know we got some
emails we got some information that
maybe it's not the best time you do that
you know like uh they said you know you
can't make any money right now this
would you would be profiting if you came
like oh no i'm buying my own plane
ticket i'm renting my own car and get my
own hotel i mean i won't even eat food
from you guys because i just don't
i don't want anything you know
and uh and he's like well the timing's
also bad you know midterms are coming up
you know you got to consider your wife's
job you got to consider she may lose it
if you get in the media again you know
they'll write stories about you again
and you know the death threats will come
and i'm like all those things are still
happening you know doing this or not i
still get letters in the mail you know
threatening my family my wife still gets
reviews from patients that are not her
patients giving her one star messing
with her credibility you know and the
news is still writing stories about me
they put together a montage a couple of
weeks ago of all of all the things i did
in the capital you know so i mean
nothing's really going to change except
for maybe there'll be one extra story
this week i thought that sure you walked
out of there with the with the lectern
so it's nice to know you put it back
down that's i thought that you just
watched it
but that's the thing a lot of people
believe that you took it out you you you
left with it well because people like
jimmy kimmel came out and said this guy
stole a lectern yeah like
i how that's interesting too because for
all anyone knew you could have just
picked it up and put it down like which
is essentially what you did uh so they
they told you it was not a good idea or
the outright said you can't do it
um
it was a no upfront it was a no upfront
uh we got a supervisor in the meeting
because i wasn't taking no for an answer
because
it's it's a free speech issue right i'm
allowed to speak there's nothing that
pleaded with saying i can't speak it
just says i can't profit you know for
the next five years so
if i get a chance to speak i'm going to
speak and it's not it's not about money
it isn't i mean like if they wanted a
lifetime plea deal where i couldn't make
money it's like i'm not signing a life
sentence with you people it's not gonna
happen so
five years seems more adequate we gotta
talk down to five years but it's not
about the money it's about being able to
speak and tell people what happened and
for the life of me we have all of these
people who weren't there telling us what
happened yeah we don't hear from people
who were actually there speaking about
it and i think we're doing a disservice
to the american people by not asking
people who actually saw things and were
actually there
so then
initially it was a no but then it turned
into a yes somehow it did um i reached
out to my attorneys and uh they are
magicians
within uh within an hour of a phone call
and conversation i won't speak about who
they talk to or what they said i got an
email saying
send me your travel itinerary i kind of
feel like the email was
if you don't let him speak the story
will be even bigger when you denied him
the right to speak i think it's
definitely that because they had hinted
well we'll take it before the judge you
know pontius pilate efforts like we're
not telling you no but we're gonna ask
the judge if we can go
and um and i again i explained to my
attorneys and he's like there's no way a
judge is gonna put his name on you're
not allowed to speak
you know and that's kind of what we
chatted about lo and behold within an
hour i get an email so here you are and
uh how have how have things been since
you mentioned you're still getting death
threats people are going after your wife
and things like that what's it like i
mean you're in florida which is good
where the god king reigns yeah so how is
it what's what's been happening after
you know since since then well we live
in we live in a pretty uh red bubble
uh where we stay so i i have a lot of
local support like a ton of local
support do people do the wave to you
when they see you i it's constant i have
a couple
it's i mean people will take pictures
with me they want to buy me a drink or
they're going to buy me a sandwich you
know like oh you're a hero you're a
patron like i moved furniture 20 yards
and someone took a picture of it you
know that's crazy how that happens
though it's like you uh
you you made a mistake
going in there obviously obviously you
did relatively little but it's become
such a powerful symbol for both the left
and the right well i think
a lot of what i hear is people say i
wish i was there with you i'm glad you
said something i'm glad you did
something you know i have people saying
like i wish you would have taken the
lectern and you know shoved it you know
somewhere to the
who owns it and i'm like well no no no
no that's not good like that's not how
we win the culture war we have that's
that's not the way forward i mean
easily that that photo is is propaganda
weaponry you know and and again like you
like jimmy kimmel you stole it is that
what yep jimmy campbell came out and
said i showed my picture that this guy
stole a podium you know and it was like
the day after it was a lectern and it
was a lectern wrong i know sources buddy
this is this is the thing i have to talk
about with the summer of love black
lives matter had net support of like 52
it was ridiculous the overwhelming
majority of this country was like yeah
black lives matter's good then the riots
happened and it tanked the the support
for black lives matter dropped lower
after the after the riots than it had
been in the lead-up to george floyd's
death when george floyd died black lives
matter support skyrocketed
and then the riots happened and
they they lost like a year of pr gains
and they've not since recovered could
have become a political party instead
but they all got a writing they should
have become political and now it's now
it's rife with scandals and weird money
stories and everything they they
imploded over that stuff nothing's going
to come of that and so so i mean here's
the it's i'll call this like a warning
as well as as a point about how people
behave when uh i've been reading about
obviously i read about civil war all the
time because i won't shut up about it
right
and i was i was thinking recently that
it's not a civil war because civil war
implies two organized factions in some
capacity fighting and i would say okay
if you're talking about information
warfare and political civil war
definitely but if we're talking about
will this lead to states seceding and
fighting
maybe
but i want to i said i want to revise
that because it may actually be more
revolutionary you know james lindsay
mentioned that words come out of
revolution you take a look at the
splitting factions within law
enforcement and the federal government
and then i started reading about uh you
know more about weimar germany because
i've i i've read a little bit
and i've read it before about the beer
hall push which is you know hitler went
into the munich beer hall and then like
you know fires a gun in the air it's
like we're taking over
and then they come and arrest him i
think some people died and then he goes
to jail and he got like a five year
sentence served like eight months
dictated mein kampf then he gets out and
then what do they do run for office
so i'll put it this way
that's a warning and also a point the
violence didn't work what worked is
winning hearts and minds and then going
and running in politics the scary thing
is a very awful and evil psychotic
person but use that to try and gain
power
now it's a bit different with soviet
russia a bunch of crazy people but
that's the left the communist stuff they
go out and get violent and then they're
allowed to do it what did james lindsey
call it
uh something tolerance repressive
tolerance impressive talent
so i wonder if we're heading towards uh
revolutionary period
you know i mean i i want to be as
white-pilled as possible i'm watching
primaries which i just voted in my first
primary ever i am no longer a registered
independent i am a registered republican
i am proud of it because i think that we
need to make a change i do i just voted
my first primary and i want to be my
pill and i'm watching what's happening
and i think i think it might actually
work i think we might actually be able
to win the culture i'm hoping we do my
fear is that the pendulum has already
been set in motion and it's the stop i
don't know where the stop point is going
to be i don't
you know with uh carrie lake winning and
it was a it was a nail biter because
like the night before it looked like she
was down a little bit and everyone was
like no way and the next day she sweeped
she swept every county and it's like oh
okay there it is that's what everyone
expected i mean she won then hageman won
joe kent won
and we're seeing you know a bunch of
primaries where america first populous
types are actually winning and it's like
now more than ever is is the time to
tell everybody like dude back away from
the violence you're winning you're
winning on these fronts now is the time
to go out rally your friends go vote
because you are winning yeah you know i
sense like it's a global revolution is
kind of what we're in the middle of
right now it's a conscious when i
started youtube in 2006 my channel said
a revolution of the mind i found out
years later that's what mao called his
culture
oops and i'm glad i got away from that
leftism cult mindset because i was
really like family is whatever your
families whatever you want it to be kind
of weird you know like going that
postmodernist route um but i definitely
think because of the internet or along
with the internet people around earth
are realizing that they're under a boot
of totalitarianism a lot of people are
they want out they like american
republicanism they love the idea of free
speech and second amendment rights a lot
of and a lot of people are able to
communicate
through their governments without their
government intervention and are kind of
there's a desire for a new world order i
mean it's very obvious that the old
liberal economic order is is faltering
yeah but i think both factions have
their own desire for a different type of
new world order that fits their own
ideologies and i think that's where we
are right now yeah there's two there's
so many different the ideas of how it
could come there's there's three there's
the liberal international economy and
that's the powerful elites the the
banking cartels the imf you know swift
payment systems international
settlements that's the brain yeah then
there's the left and they want a
socialist utopian revolution worker
rights and then there's the right they
want a national uh you know reemergence
nationalist re-emergence of sovereign
nations that have international treaties
and ties and things like that one of
those sounds like a good time yeah yeah
you know my attitude is like hey i like
the idea of um global governance via
treaty
meaning like no um council of elites who
can strip your rights from you but um
potentially a world court is preferable
to world war i sure but that would mean
that within the borders of a country
that they have no authority it is only
outside the borders between countries
where they would they would they would
intervene in any capacity i love it it's
an extension of federalism united states
federalism it's it's got to be i mean it
makes so much sense it sort of would
adopt that the federal government has
the ability in the united states to go
to states and enforce law i'm saying not
that i'm saying there would be no global
court that could go into illinois and
arrest someone for an international
thing it would be it would be up to the
country to actually go and do it but if
there was an issue of like a u.s plane
flying over to another country and then
doing something that's when a world
court would intervene and be like we're
going to stop this and not allow it so
it would only be a direct international
matters and my point there is like for
one maybe maybe you need some thinking
and maybe there's an argument and
debates to be made over it but i'm kind
of like hey how do you stop world war
how do you stop you from blowing each
other up well i don't want anybody
coming to america and being like you
can't do this you can't do that no we're
our country we have our borders we will
function the way we deem is right for us
you go do your thing instead of us going
and bombing each other maybe there is a
mediation system in world court that
will the one of the mediation systems
that's being pushed is um this uh what
do you call it uh social credit score
they think that if you can like get
people to self-censor and kind of
control people's money that then you
will pacify them
but you know pacification often in times
means like destruction and death of
people when they're like we're going to
pacify the population that's very nice
because pacifists don't want war but in
reality when you see what happens when
someone pacifies a country is oftentimes
bombs are being dropped the military is
no longer able to fight back kind of i
don't want that and i don't like the
social credit score stuff i don't know
but i feel like we're doing it to
ourselves with up votes and down votes
on social media and likes and stuff yep
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and we'll see you all
there
you